it's a Wednesday edition of PFT oh t we
usually do PFT ot after PFT live ends
but because there is no PFT live and
will be no PFT live until July 29 we
just do PFT ot it doesn't make a whole
lot of sense but what the hell here I am
and let's talk about the things
happening in the national football
league on this fine Wednesday morning
I'm gonna start in Cleveland because I
love Baker Mayfield I love the passion I
love the fire
I love the intensity I love the fact
that he's so different from what we
usually see in an NFL quarterback in
that he speaks his mind he's largely
unfiltered and for the most part he's
got the charisma to pull it off now his
latest comment that is causing some
consternation for some the idea that he
desperately wanted revenge against
former Browns coach Hugh Jackson after
Jackson left the Browns he was fired and
became an assistant with the Cincinnati
Bengals coincidentally the Browns had
yet to play the Bengals at all in 2018
and still had two games against them and
that pissed off Baker Mayfield now
Baker's reasoning is you've got a guy
who's in the locker room saying we're
doing everything we can to try to win on
behalf of the Cleveland Browns and now
he defects to another organization and
you know at at a very basic visceral
level I understand why he feels that way
and there's a certain appeal to it and I
think the NFL should love that a young
NFL quarterback is pushing this concept
because it shows a complete lack of
appreciation for the business reality of
the NFL and maybe Baker Mayfield is
always going to be this way you know my
first thought is ah he's young he's
maybe a little naive he doesn't
understand how it works yet he thinks
it's like high school or college and it
isn't and he's yet to get that that that
harsh dose of reality that football
really is a business and maybe he never
will and maybe even if he does he will
willingly play the role of guy who makes
everyone else think it's not a business
and and that's the key the NFL
desperately wants the fans to not
realize that at its core it's a business
and Baker Mayfield weather
he knows that her doesn't is saying
things that would suggest that it really
isn't a business the idea that there's
some sort of an insult that was worked
upon the Cleveland Browns
because Baker Mayfield after or because
Hugh Jackson rather after he was fired
by the Browns went to the Cincinnati
Bengals well he was fired right and he's
got to be right to go wherever he wants
to go after he's been fired now he was
working for free for the Bengals and
maybe he went to the Bengals because he
wanted to stick it to the Browns because
he was upset about what happened and
maybe that that makes Baker may feel a
little more upset than he otherwise
should be or could be or would be but
the reality is Jackson was fired I
didn't go wherever he wants and if the
Browns wanted to keep Hugh Jackson from
joining a competitor in the division you
you don't fire him you keep him as your
head coach it's that simple
the other comment from Baker Mayfield in
recent weeks that it feeds this idea
that he doesn't understand it's a
business or he does and he's just
willing to act like it's not a business
the Duke Johnson remarks the whole idea
of get on the train or get off the train
or you're the with us or you're not when
Duke Johnson clearly wants to be traded
and remember those remarks sparked
backlash reportedly from some veteran
players who realize that no players
should get between a man and his
business situation Duke Johnson's trying
to improve his business situation
because ultimately it is a business so I
think it's a refreshing attitude even
though it is a very naive attitude from
Baker Mayfield and it could cause some
problems if that attitude is ever
directed to teammates like it already
has been but but the NFL needs more guys
who will help push this idea that
football is in a business even though it
really is a business you know they say
football is family know football is
business and it's good for business to
say football his family but you know
that doesn't really fit on the bumper
sticker all right
there's business going on for the Denver
Broncos they are reporting for training
camp on Wednesday physicals and a
meeting tonight with coach Vic Fangio
and then they'll get down to it they
they get to report early because they're
playing in the Hall of Fame game against
the Falcons they're reporting without
second-round quarterback drew Locke he
is on
signed and there aren't many guys who
are unsigned but he's reportedly
unsigned this comes from my Cliffs of
nine news in Denver because drew Locke
wants a quarterback premium now I
haven't heard the term quarterback
premium in a while cliff says that that
his research suggests it's been five
well the Denver Broncos research that
was handed to Mike list suggests that
it's been five years since there's been
a quarterback premium paid I just
assumed that that went away as part of
this rookie wage scale which really
trims down what can be negotiated and I
didn't think that that the dollar
amounts to be paid to a quarterback were
negotiable now maybe there are other
terms that you can finagle other than
dollars that reflect the fact that
you're a quarterback but you know here's
the bottom line the Broncos have to
decide are they going to blink whatever
it is that CAA wants on behalf of drew
Locke to get him to show up will the
Broncos say okay we'll do it because we
want this guy here and we want this guy
learning the ropes so he'll be ready to
go in the event that Joe Flacco gets
injured or Joe Flacco is ineffective as
starting quarterback of the Denver
Broncos so something to keep an eye on
because it becomes much harder for a
rookie quarterback to contribute if he's
not there every step of the way and he
could be a holdout officially today and
he could start missing practices later
this week if they don't work out a new
contract that would get him in the fold
with the Denver Broncos in Tennessee
there's a lot of optimism about what
running back Derrick Henry can do in
2019 he's been kind of up and down so
far in his NFL career remember last year
second half of the season he really
found the gas pedal and I spoke to him
after a couple of great games it started
with that Thursday night spectacular
performance against the Jacksonville
Jaguars and he told me that during a bye
week he went back studied his film self
scouted himself as Chris Simms would say
and he realized he was trying too hard
to hit a home run on every play and he
decided he was just gonna take what was
there and he was gonna be patient and
eventually the yards would come and they
came in significant numbers for Derrick
Harvey in Derrick Henry rather in the
second part of the season so this year
reportedly he's expected to get plenty
of carries plenty of opportunities and
look if he can stay healthy this is a
guy who can become a battery
ramp type of running back for the Titans
and make it so much easier for marcus
mariota to throw the football and
remember from REO - the key is he's got
to stay healthy this year or the Titans
aren't gonna be interested in keeping
around but for Derrick Henry the notion
that he is going to be the centerpiece
of the offense that he's going to get
those opportunities that he's going to
get a chance to build upon what he did
in the second half of the season
something that could be very very
intriguing for a Titans team that may
have an offense far different than what
we're used to seeing now in the NFL
we're seeing a lot of teams pass the
ball and I know the Ravens have gone run
heavier at least they're making us think
they're going to go run heavy for 2019
it could be run heavy for the Tennessee
Titans which could be good news for a
Titans team that has kind of become
forgotten in the AFC South given the
fact that the Texans of the defending
champions that the jaguars seem to be
better and the Colts are on the rise but
let's not overlook the Titans because if
they can get some consistency they can
be a very very good team we saw them
like maybe no other team in the NFL last
year rise up to the level of competition
but then the following week slide down
to the level of a team that they should
have easily beaten in New York the Jets
are just trying to get in a position
where they can compete with the New
England Patriots are really the other
great teams in the AFC and part of the
strategy for doing that was signing
running back Le'Veon Bell once he became
a free agent and now the question is how
much will they use Le'Veon belt he's
been out of football for a year he
didn't show up for much of the offseason
program coach Adam GaSe recently
commented on that balance that you have
to strike you don't want to overuse a
guy and there's I guess a gut level
sense as to how much you really do give
the ball to lay beyond bail either
through handoffs or swing passes out of
the backfield and I don't know how it's
gonna play out and I think it is gonna
come down to that that almost sixth
sense that Adam GaSe will have developed
over his years of coaching as to when a
running back is being used too much or
when he still has gas in the tank but
they're paying this guy not to be a
part-time player they're paying this guy
to be a workhorse so the presumption is
he will be a workhorse but the challenge
is if you throw him into the fray too
aggressively given that he didn't play
at all last year maybe he ends up
getting himself injured and
you know even though injuries can happen
to anything running back no matter
whether they sat out last year or didn't
if he does get injured early in the year
specifically the arguments gonna be well
you should have known that after sitting
out a full year who's gonna be prone to
injury and you shouldn't used him as
much as you did so this is going to be I
only want to call it a good problem to
have it could be a bad problem to have
for the Jets because I think they are
constantly going to be concerned about
getting bail injured by using him too
much and that's one of the reasons why
maybe you don't pay him as much as you
paid him and remember the reports after
the firing of Jets GM Mike mechag knee
that Adam GaSe didn't want to pay lady
on bail the money that the Jets
ultimately did and I think this is one
of the reasons why because for this year
particularly there's going to be an
ongoing tension as to how much is too
much in the use of running back lay
beyond bail all right a report emerged
from 106 7 the fan in DC earlier this
week that Washington and guard Brandon
Scherff are far apart in contract talks
and this doesn't really bode well when
you consider the numbers involved here
and Scherff was a top 10 pick so he is
entitled this year to or next year
rather no this year let me get that
straight this year is the 5th year of
his contract he gets last year's
transition tender for offensive lineman
that is 12 and a half million dollars
for Brandon sheriff in 2019 and what
that does is it sets the stage for 12
million it's 12 million dollars this
year for Brandon Scherff that sets the
stage for a franchise tag next year of
15 million that is a lot for an interior
offensive lineman so the two sides are
far apart in contract talks presumably
because cherf is looking at his
contractual situation and realizing look
I get 12 million this year and next year
if they tag me I get 15 million and if
they don't tag me I go to the open
market so why am I gonna do a deal for
12 million a year or 11 million a year
or 13 million a year you know and this
is how Washington screwed it up with
Kirk Cousins they tagged him consecutive
years but they never offered in the kind
of long-term deal that prompted him to
say I'll take the long-term deal over
the franchise tag Cousins chose to go
year-to-year because of the quality
offers made by Washington and sure could
do the same thing
and if he does he'll make 33 million
dollars between 2020 and 2024 21 that's
16 and a half million a year that's an
average higher than any offensive
lineman currently in football so cherf
has the leverage here and and the report
specifically from one of 67 the fan is
that Washington has made multiple offers
to Brandon Scherff Annika how many
offers they may think you make a
thousand offers if none of them is good
enough it doesn't matter
cherf has the leverage by virtue of the
fact that he was a top 10 draft pick in
now entering year 5 12 million dollars
15 million in 2020 18 million in 2021
it's very easy to do the math and figure
out what he should be asking for on a
long-term deal or more accurately what
Washington should be paying if they want
to work something out and keep him
around and for a change find a way to
financially reward one of their own guys
instead of having good young players who
get started with Washington become free
agents and get paid elsewhere I think
it's very powerful to find ways to sign
those guys and keep them and keep the
signing of veterans who made their way
with another team and give those
strangers to the organization big money
you keep that to a minimum that's the
way to get the most out of your young
players because you're letting your
young players know if you do everything
that's expected of you you too will be
getting a financial reward without
having to change teams that's it for
this Wednesday edition of pft ot will do
again on Thursday we'll do it again on
Friday and we will be posting content
all day long every day of the year at
Pro Football talk.com see you Thursday
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports